Zarkon baka Stella was one of Germany's  most telegenic and popular winter  athletes winning gold in women's  cross-country skiing at the 2002 and  2010 Winter Olympics at the 2006 game  she was given a five-day suspension due  to elevated hemoglobin levels but  bounced back to win silver at the age of  33 is a kombucha Stella made her Olympic  debut as a biathlete in Sochi finishing  fourth in the 12.5 kilometer mass start  raised but her hopes of conquering the  biathlon were quashed after blood tests  showed evidence of a banned stimulant  the German Ski Federation says the  levels may have been caused by a dietary  supplement the fall from grace of one of  Germany's most prominent winter athletes  is shorter send shockwaves far beyond  Sochi